[موسيقى]
التقى نجوم السينما في مهرجان القاهره
السينمائيه الرابع والاربعين وهو اقدم
المهرجانات الدوليه في الشرق الاوسط
وافريقيا
[موسيقى]
انا بالاقي انه ده مهرجان
يعني
وقف في احلى الفترات وكمل احنا النهارده
فاتحين دراعاتنا لكل
[موسيقى]
العالميه في مصر
فهم يعود هذا العام يراس المهرجان بعد
اكثر من 20 عاما وكان اول تصريحاته تحديد
معايير لازياء الفنانين فهل ينجح هذا
القرار في الحد من الجدل الذي يسار دوما
على السوشيال ميديا حول ازياء الفنانين
والفنانات بصراحه انا بالنسبه لي
المهرجانات دي هي هي
فكرتها الافلام يعني اه نلبس ممكن نلبس
لكن نفس الوقت ما يكونش بس هو ده نيجي
نتمشى على الريق ونخش بقى نحضر او ما
نشوفش الفيلم
انا بالنسبه لي مهم جدا ان شارك فيه
فعاليات المهرجان ونشوف افلام بالنهايه هو
مهرجان ايه
التجهيزات
الافلام اللي جبناها عشان تتعرض على
الجمهور السينما اللي بيحبه الفن همم
ثقافات مختلفه جايه من جميع انحاء العالم
لجنه تحكيم درجه اولى من الطراز الاول
الرابعه
فهو عنده خبره وانا بهنيك زميله كان رئيس
مهرجان بهاني من كل قلبي يعني
97% طويلا و 18 في المنصيرا من اثنتين
وخمسين دوله تشارك في مسابقات المهرجان من
هذه الافلام نحو 30 فيلم منها عرض عالمي
اول ونحو 60 فلما عرض اول في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا اما فيلم الافتتاح فهو فيلم
ذا فايبرنس او الفي بالمنز للمخرج ستيفنر
[موسيقى]
يعني قد يكون ده واحد من الانتصارات
وفي تقدم كبير همم في مجال صناعه السينما
ان شاء الله الفتره الجايه واا وظهور وجوه
جديده من ممثلين والمخرجين ده
ملحوظ جدا وبشكل قوي جدا السينما العربيه
مش شايفه ازاي الفتره اللي فاتت دي فيه
يعني نشاط مكثف في ملاحظينه شايفه ده ازاي
لا شايفاه هايل وشايفه فعلا في نشاط جميل
جدا وفي اعمال ناجحه جدا وهمم اهم حاجه
الايرادات الايرادات طالما انها بتبقى
ارادات قويه وجامده والفيل بيقعد كثير في
السينما فبالتالي همم ده في المناجح وهادف
يكرم المهرجان المخرج المصريه كامله ابو
ذكري المخرج المداريه
والفنانه لبلبه التي تزامت تكريم مع يوم
ميلادها وفجاه همه
[تصفيق]
المهرجان في فعالياته التي تستمر 9 ايام
احدث ما وصلت اليه السينما العربيه
والعالميه من حيث التقنيات والتجارب
الشبابيه وخاصه من الدول العربيه
من القاهره